this view should absolutely freak you
out as much as team one has helped you
to breathe and do press-ups looking at
the standing in front of the microphone
looking at all those people staring back
at you should still make you nervous and
frankly after ten weeks of having great
coaching who still gets nervous when
they have to present now I know team one
asses question so I saw of you put your
hands up so well we have good news for
you today because the reality is after
practicing and practicing and practicing
even more you will continue to freak out
and the reason that that's good news is
because being nervous has its uses it
reminds you that you care it helps you
be authentic and at the GSB it's what we
love right and I think comedian mr.
Lindy put it best which is if I
completely lost my nervousness I would
be completely frightened to death so I
think there's a role that nervousness
can play when we speak and today we tell
you we're here to help you embrace
freaking out now today we have three
great guests with us each of them suffer
from freaking out in a slightly
different way so we have with us miss
situational we have with us mr. audience
and we have dr. gold now each one of
them will go through a little bit about
what makes them freak out and then share
a little bit about how they embrace it
anyway without further ado I'd like to
welcome my first guest Z also known as
Miss situation so I used to be very
nervous
when I have to come in front of people
and speak but then I figured out why I
was nervous and I was able to implement
techniques to help me with it so more
specifically I read the book by Matt
Abrams speaking out without freaking out
and I discovered that my source of
nervousness is called the situation
based anxiety what does that mean so
that means I'm nervous because of the
situation or context I'm in when I'm
speaking to people so to give you guys
an example to illustrate this let's say
James is outside speaking with a few of
his friends about his startup he's not
nervous at all and he knows the topic
very well but then it's JD was to come
and ask him to present in front of one
hundred a few hundred people James would
be very nervous and that's what we call
situational based anxiety he's nervous
because of the situation he's in so
aspect ratio
talked about earlier in the presentation
one of the reasons why you're nervous is
that you see it no longer as a
conversation but as a performance and
you see it as having one right way of
communicating your message so as an
actor or performer there's a write in a
wrong way
if you hit miss your cues other actors
on stage are going to be confused your
light and sound people aren't going to
know what's going on but the good thing
about speaking is that there isn't just
one right way of doing it
there's definitely better and worse ways
but there isn't one right way so by
reframing the situation into a
conversation as opposed to a performance
you're much more likely to remove some
of that anxiety so I know it's a little
more difficult than just saying imagine
having a conversation with 200 people
sitting in front of you so I'm going to
give you guys a few techniques that you
can use to do this the first one is to
practice conversational so instead of
practicing in front of standing up in
front of pretending to be in front of
people practice or buy like the dinner
table or at coffee I actually practiced
early on the phone right so practice
conversationally second use questions so
these can be rhetorical questions but by
using questions you're engaging the
audience and it becomes a dialogue and a
dialogue is a conversation
so you can start by using questions
finally the third thing I'd like to
share with you guys is to speak
conversational a lot of people when they
get in front of a group of people to
present they feel like they have to use
formal language but the reality is when
we're speaking everyday we don't use
formal language I would encourage you
guys to use the word to you use a very
powerful word and it connects you with
your audience and so use it it's one of
a great tool that you guys have so with
that I hope that you guys find these
techniques useful and try them out if
what you think you have is situational
based anxiety thank you so much see next
up we have Chris also known as mr.
audience so I may look calm relaxed at
ease and friendly right now but it
wasn't always like that in fact there
was a time when a situation like this
clammy palms
high-pitched voice forgetting my lines
the whole nine yards but that changed
and it wasn't by accident it was
actually kind of like an old joke that
many of you may have heard already how
do you get to Carnegie Hall practice
practice practice and in particular one
of the practice techniques I used was a
visualization and over the course of
this research I actually found that
there's over 30 years of academic
science backing up the idea that
visualization is one of the best ways to
deal with anxiety when dealing with an
audience so what is visualization
anyways a lot of you are probably
already familiar with it it's sort of
seeing success happen in your mind it's
when your coach told you that you could
make the Big Shot land the perfect dive
or play that piano piece perfectly and
visualization translates well into
performance into giving talks into
presentations so at this point you might
be thinking like that's great but I
don't want to become a peewee football
star I'm talking to hundreds maybe
thousands of people how can I use
visualization to improve my
and before we answer that question I
think it's good to take a step back and
think about what's actually driving the
audience anxiety in the first place so
if you really consider it for a moment
you realized that what makes you or at
least what makes many people ill the
ease about the audience they're speaking
to is that they don't know who they is
you know your audience might not have
the same level of knowledge about the
subject matter they might have power
over you or you know you might want to
approve to preserve or improve your
relationship with them and so that's
where visualization comes into play well
before you actually give a talk like
this what you want to do is come to the
venue where you'll actually be speaking
stand in the middle of floor soak it all
in imagine your audience in front of you
and then see them in your mind's eye
responding positively to your message so
even me right now a couple days ago I
was in here kind of looking around
soaking it in and now you know the key
is that it makes you feel desensitized
to the experience so that when you come
in front of your audience it's that big
moment it's not new to you it's all hat
so I want to finish up now that we've
talked about sort of how to use
visualization we talked about what it is
I'm gonna take one quick minute talk
about what it's not visualization is not
rehearsing your speech again and again
in your head that can actually be
counterproductive because ironically
you're going to get performance anxiety
if you do that your goal with
visualization is to get yourself to a
good mental comfort level with the
people in venue early speaking with and
that's how you'll improve audience
anxiety thanks Chris and then last but
not least yes people call me dr. goal
because because first of all I'm a
doctor in engineering second I always
set high standards for everything I will
do for example when I give presentation
to the audience it's not be perfect the
process the result the the message I'm
delivering they got to be perfect let me
tell you a story
when I was working before coming to GSB
I used to frequently give presentations
to group of people from different in
this from people in the industry and
companies trying to convince them to buy
their product from technical point of
view
so before presentation I used to I used
to think this presentation that'd be
perfect
otherwise I may lose my job or then I
will lose my apartment oh maybe I will
lose my wife my family then I got I want
to have food to eat I will start with
them to that then you can see how this
escalate from failure of a presentation
or possible failure of presentation to a
test life threatening event just to say
you very care you very care about the
results because you took care about the
possible consequence so that's what I
experienced then how did I overcome this
I got two techniques to overcome this
goal-oriented nervousness the first
technique is to accept the worst
consequence and then do your best to
build whatever you can upon it let me
give you an example now I'm doing
presentation here in the United States
at the GSB thousand smell miles away
from my home country China and well
what's gonna happen if I screw up then
here I'm using James English name not
using my real name in China and it's far
away from there no one loves me that
much then I just said if I screwed up I
just say sayonara and see you all guys
in Japan
yes if you are from Japan use another
country so when I accepted this
consequence then I feel more relaxed
when I gave the presentation the second
technique you can use is to try to focus
on the present when you are actually
before you are actually walking on the
stage I was actually doing push-ups when
I was there and I already did five and
we get five I think it helped it helps
you to focus on the present because when
when you are doing push-ups actually
your brain is is stucked in that moment
you cannot thinking of anything else
with just counting the push-ups and hope
so that's the second technique you can
use try to do something to force
yourself focus on the present and I hope
these two techniques will help you
especially the first one the example
three very different ways that people
typically freak out now some of our
guests also shared a few methods in
which they use to embrace they're
freaking out but there's one thing
that's important to know and that is
they picked ways that worked for them
because most commonly when people try
and address this issue of freaking out
when they speak they try and pick the
three or four things that other people
suggest that they should do often that
doesn't quite work and then people freak
out even more and no matter how many
times you take JD's class you're doomed
you think you're doomed to be a bad
speaker so actually what we encourage
you to do is to use Matt Abrams book
inside this book there are 35 proven
techniques that you can help embrace
you're freaking out and we suggest that
you understand what drives our anxiety
and then pick the techniques that work
for you
now before we lay out guests go I want
to make sure that we help you along in
your journey towards embracing your
freaking out so are there any questions
that I can direct to our wonderful
guests here today
please
big part which one has possible
see so I'd say it I definitely think
it's like a very personal thing and as
James was mentioning you kind of need to
find the techniques that work for you
and I think it's the same thing in terms
of cause of your anxiety it's gonna be
not only based on what when you're
talking in general but also on the
situation and context that you're in
right it might sometimes be the goal
that's the most stressful and sometimes
it might be just because there's a
thousand people in the room right and so
I think you just need to work on
whatever techniques help you and just
it's a learning process and know that at
all times you're still going to be
nervous so to continue like working on
finding you take an exam you have
questions
please and that's a tough situation
Oh actually when I was in China I was
doing the presentation I tried to
convince me even if I screwed up this
presentation I'm gonna be fine
the worst case is I lose this job and
then try to find it try to find another
one I just try to convince myself okay
this is not that important you just do
your best that's the technique I used I
just made aiya
so you them home when I was doing
sanitation here that's a sure one that
immediately its mind and as I was
speaking I skipped over it
Abraham recommends sort of like digging
into like find out exactly who your
audience will be so like particularly
said you know get on facebook google
them you know LinkedIn and I think
that's a little bit of overkill I think
that to the extent that you can focus on
the issues and anxieties driving you
rather than trying to sort of get inside
the heads of the audience before you
start speaking that'll serve you better
thank you for your questions now
remember situation audience and gold
pick from the menu for what works for
you thank you